you're into someone you can tell bad
news to and they won't tell you why
you're an idiot and they won't interfere
with yourself they'll just listen and
maybe they'll suffer along with you and
they won't tell you some worst thing
that happened to them they'll listen but
a friend is also someone you can tell
good news to and the friend will say wow
in this veil of Tears something good
happened to you great man I'm wonderful
it's rare it's unlikely good for you I
hope 10 more things like that happen
they're not envious and they're not
jealous and they're not one up in you if
you're trying to get your life together
and your friends get in the way that's
actually real useful for you because
you've now identified who your friends
aren't and you might think well I can't
give them up it's like oh yes you can
and not only can you you should and it
would be better for them because if
they're aiming down and they want you
going down with them there's nothing
good about what's happening to them and
there's certainly nothing good about
that for you